today we had a horrible thing happen it
happens every once in a while we have a
guest scheduled beautiful guest and uh
they no call no show giving us no notice
whatsoever that they are not planning to
join the interview but the upside is
we'll hear from a few of you
via discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go first
to rose from the united states rose it's
the united states is so general but
welcome
uh hello can you hear me
yes i can
oh uh the art equality is fine i know
you're quite a stickler for it it's it's
quite good thank you
okay um
yeah well um i i really feel
uncomfortable disclosing my location on
the internet um
that being said uh my question is
there's a really big gap
between
scientists and the general public
and it feels like the gap keeps growing
and it gets more and more difficult to
convey to the general public
the
precise nature of science and the
difficulties associated with it it feels
like scientists are failing as a
political entity
to
talk to the general public how do you
feel about this i agree with you i mean
i think here's the thing
if you told mo my i'm not a scientist
but i my instinct is if you told
scientists you are failing as a
political entity they would say we're
not a political entity and i but at the
same time i acknowledge what you're
saying which is
we i mean maybe it's science education
that's failing and critical thinking and
epistemology i don't i don't know but
you're absolutely right in your your
observation about the effects of it
what what can we do because
i've i've spent so much time thinking
about this because
in light of global warming
it's way worse than what most reports
suggest
the most people don't know this but the
ipcc
is
meant to be a sort of a politically
favorable take on it it doesn't take
into account multiple feedback loops um
including the thawing of the permafrost
and the arctic
uh it doesn't take take into account
ocean salinity which changes demonstrate
to dissolve in the oceans etc so there
like multiple feedback loops going on
all of which suggest
that the reality of climate change is
going to be way worse than what most
people expect
the situation is more dire in other
words
yes yes uh the ipcc reports are the best
case scenario the best possible
hypothetical scenario
and it's
and yet so many scientists i know
personally and i've talked to them about
this
they are
they struggle to get people to
understand this and they worry that if
they
actually talk about what's going to
happen
uh with real precision and actual facts
that they'll be dismissed as a
apocalyptic loons right so and and
they're probably
they're probably correct to think that
that's what would happen
yeah i don't know how to bridge the gap
rose i mean this is this is an ongoing
conversation where
for it almost feels too late for so many
people and there's also the political
machine that that wants to stay on
fossil fuels that we're up against and
we need to start teaching critical
thinking and media literacy very early i
actually have a bunch of books
uh
waiting to be read on a pile that deal
directly with this issue and so i'm
hoping in a few months maybe i'll have
some greater insights into it but
you're at least identifying the problem
correctly could you share the book list
um i'd i'd love to read it i will once
i've read the books because i always
want to read books before i recommend
them but absolutely
okay um it was great talking to you
today rose thank you so much absolutely
you too thank you thanks david all right
there is rose with a very
dystopian but necessary
commentary